hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
i thank esther from hungary for
suggesting this topic
start out with the quadrilateral where
two of its opposite sides have the same
length of x
label the vertices a b c and d
as typical with math diagrams this
diagram is not to scale
let angle a be 90 degrees and let angle
b be 100 degrees
now draw perpendicular bisectors for
sides a b and c d and mark the
intersection point as e
on a b we'll draw the perpendicular
bisector and on cd we'll draw the
perpendicular bisector and we'll mark
the intersection point as e
because e is on the perpendicular
bisector of a b it is equidistant to a
and b
so these two sides will have the same
length which we'll mark as y
next because e is on the perpendicular
bisector of cd it is equidistant to c
and d
so we'll mark these two sides with the
letter z
now let's focus on one part of this
diagram
the triangles ead and ebc have three
equal sides so they are congruent
thus angles ead and ebc must have equal
measure and will mark those angles as
alpha
now let's focus on a different part of
the diagram
now triangles fae and fbe have three
equal sides so once again they are
congruent
and the angles fae and fbe must have
equal measure and we'll mark them
as the angle being beta
now let's go back to our bigger diagram
and the angles for a and b
by the given information bad is equal to
90 degrees and abc is equal to 100
degrees
but we just demonstrated that angle bad
is equal to alpha plus beta which equals
90 degrees and angle abc is equal to
alpha plus beta which equals 100 degrees
therefore we've proven that 90 degrees
is equal to alpha plus beta is equal to
100 degrees and so we've shown that 90
is equal to 100
but this is an absurd result
so the question to you is where is the
mistake in this seemingly convincing
proof can you figure it out give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution
so where is the mistake in this proof
to illustrate it i'm going to scale the
diagram down
because i'm going to draw the
perpendicular bisectors a little bit
more accurately
we'll draw the perpendicular bisector
for a b and then we'll draw the
perpendicular bisector for cd
notice they meet but when we mark the
point e it's on the exterior of abcd
the point e where the perpendicular
bisectors meet is not interior to the
shape abcd
this is where the mistake in the proof
originates
but why does this little detail matter
well let's connect e to a b c and d
the consequence that e is on the
exterior is that the steps where we
found equal angles summing to 90 and 100
degrees were incorrect
notice that abc is not equal to cbe plus
fbe and bad is not equal to ead plus fae
so our steps do not prove that angles
bad and abc are equal and therefore we
cannot prove that 90 equals a hundred
this false proof demonstrates an
important lesson you have to be careful
about assuming the location of a
constructed point especially with
diagrams not drawn to scale
did you figure out the mistake
thanks for watching these math videos
which can be watched for free on youtube
inspire and build confidence for people
around the world and they already have
over a hundred million views let's share
the beauty of mathematics with your help
we can map the world a better place
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos watch and share all of
mind your decisions videos email me a
puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com
and if you so choose you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards thanks for
watching and thanks for your support